[музыка]
добрый вечер и the state of мы сегодня я
хочу с вами говорить по-русски
последние несколько недель я
раз в неделю я говорю по
на одном иностранном языке я уже это
делал лапа китайский французский и
японский
португальский и сейчас по-русски но я я
очень хочу объяснить почему я изучал
русский это все начинал семь лет тому
назад я юноши когда у меня был я не знаю
16 лет мне очень нравилось русская
литература то стоит достоевский и
тургенев и я всегда хотел читать эти
книги на русском
это был один очень важное
важным причинам и потом потому что я
изучал много
язык языков русский стал моим 11
одни из этого языка и я всегда не очень
беспокоиться или я не очень сосредоточен
сотри сосредоточимся на грамматике
почему поскольку когда у меня нет
никакого опыта с языком все все эти
объяснения это очень трудно очень трудно
понимать очень трудно вспомнить
но после того что у меня есть опыт если
я смогу
смог много читать и слушать но когда я
читаю эти грамматические
книги ну я немножко понимаю и я могу
немножко вспомнить и поэтому когда
изучали но 80 процентов время
времени я читаю и и слушаю и
и это тоже был случай на моей изучения
русского языка
когда я нашла я слушал конечно очень
простые уроки
но после несколько месяцев я начинал
читать и слушать аудиокнигу
толстого крыться рвасса над а потому что
это это короткая книга это не война и
мир
и я был в риге
один раз я купил там книгу и я это
много-много раз
слушал и потом был а отцы и дети
тургенева и тоже я нашел аудиокнигу и
тексте я могу найти интернете
импортировать на линк мой
сайта изучения языка и там читать и
сохранять слова слова слова и фразы
которые мне нужен нужны и и это я
один-то тени много лет пять лет укла по
три я начну когда у меня гости сидят и в
течение 5 лет я каждый день я слышу
русский час но иногда
если уже потому что отпуске или но в
машине или когда я не знаю работаю в
доме или что-то я всегда слышал сушу ну
последних 22 года
я больше всего занимал чешском и
корейском ный португальском но прежде я
могу сказать пять лет был сосредоточен
на русском и это и я после я или кроме
как ром и литературы и
и я нашел очень интересный веб-сайт
который называется эхо москвы и там
я могу слушать и читать и я могу
импортировать и звук и текст до наш сайт
ли где я могу используем использовать
это интервью это содержание для того
чтобы выучить самая
yazik но я не только выучил немножко
русский но я много много узнал о россия
потому что вояка москве есть не не
только точка зрения
но тоже там приедут в гости как это его
завис там им ты реалистка майка
прохорова или там camry задание придут и
представительно и думает ну много есть
той же программе
истории о
экология экономика много много вещей
поэтому я могу сказать я прежде чем я
начну выучить русский я почти ничего не
знал о россии и сейчас я немножко знаю я
думаю что это это самая важная как это
сказать последствия когда мы изучаем
язык это не только способ общения это не
только способ коммуникации это
это окна это 2 который открывается и нам
позволяет открыт новый мир
а между прочим вот я вам расскажу
несколько дней этого назад я был в одном
магазине здесь
ваньку который называется русскими
потому что я довольно часто там покупаю
книги или я потому что мне очень
нравится советские фильмы
и там я могу купить дивизия до фильме
советского
время времени
время дома как который является
владельцы
этого магазина мне сказала что
матвейка на польский язык в москве будет
ванкувер и будет там сдавать конференции
но я я слушаю этого
это я этого я очень-очень рада вас и я
не только решил что буду участвовать в
конференции но когда я вернем вернулись
домой но я немедленно послать имейл гана
по узкому и сказал ему что хочу им
пригласить пригласить на объект или ужин
во время его пребывания в массы орган
google и но я не получил обед но
несколько дней спустя получила звонок
доме и белла и это дома из-за русскими и
она мне сказала что она органа pусский
находится находится магазине и
хочет со мной говорить ну я говорила
польский гамов который я слышал в
течение 5 лет и он мне сказал что он
будет центре города несколько часов если
у меня есть времени а я могу с ним
встретится но
конечно я пошел там и с ним встречи и мы
говорили значит он говорили о служу
потому что это очень-очень горячий
человек очень-очень энергетический очень
дружества ней он много много говорил о
ситуациях россия
спаси ему несколько объяснений все что
сейчас происходит в россии берете
интересно но это это один пример
насколько изучение языка может быть
интересно может носить много-много
преимущество преимуществ для меня
открытия русский мир это посади 67 лет
это стан большая часть моей жизни и я
думаю что если мы все будем питаться
выучить друг с друга друг друга
заимствование наши языки я думаю наш мир
думаю нашим мир будет немножко более
и для меня спорт я не знаю но все таки
мне очень нравится
русская культура это очень горячие много
спорного много controversy и да и я это
очень интересно посмотрите и но я я я
надеюсь что я желаю вам удачи на ваше
изучение языка не только английский
английского и французского китайского
что и
[музыка]
хочу что мы можем встретиться в линьки
тоже до свидания спасибо за то что вы
слушали меня и последующих 3 до свидания